[Applause]
yes indeedy
be Thursday everybody
ah yeah
something happened
we'll get to that the Trump indictment
news and the B Block so stick around for
that but first it's almost the weekend
which means which means kudlow's getting
the jacuzzi Power Scrub just in time
that's the only way to get all that
Jello out
ah
we the commissioner of the national
National League or nil
said they will evaluate whether to
continue Pride nights where players are
expected to wear rainbow colored jerseys
to show support for the lgbtq community
he says quote players may not feel
comfortable wearing the uniform as a
form of endorsement and he calls it a
distraction so once again like a virus
wokeness invades an arena and creates
unnecessary conflict and not the fun
kind of conflict like this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to think politics is destroying the
sweet wholesomeness of hockey
but it's true this obligatory virtue
signal is now forcing some players to
defend their beliefs earlier this year
Philadelphia Flyers defenseman Ivan
provorov made headlines when he refused
to wear a pride night Jersey citing his
faith he didn't condemn anybody or try
to tell anybody how to live their lives
he just refused to participate
I bet he respects everybody's choices
and I respect everybody's choices my
choice is to stay true to myself and my
religion
that's all I'm gonna say and
they should need to say in the United
States of America but he was condemned
as a homophobe anyway it was quickly
followed by a lifetime ban of Broadway
musicals and shopping at Pottery Barn
then there's Eric and Mark Stahl from
the Florida Panthers who sat out
warm-ups during last week's Pride night
game they too cited religion but also
said quote we carry no judgment on how
people choose to live their lives all
people should be welcome in hockey and
the entire Chicago Blackhawks team
decided against wearing Pride jerseys
because it's Russian players don't want
to be killed when they return home for
replacing for embracing a lifestyle that
Putin doesn't even if Putin does love
riding bareback and shirtless
tell me that's not gay
man please don't kill me so now you got
at least six NHL teams deciding to
Knicks The Pride jerseys altogether
I really don't care what they wear in a
perfect world they they'd all be
shirtless but what a stark contrast to
the wimps at Major League Baseball who
bowed to the woke when they moved the
All-Star game from Atlanta to Denver
because activists had called the new
voting law racist and it wasn't
but we should have known that MLB would
have no balls ever since they started
taking steroids
gloves when they hear someone won't
conform but now maybe that's over
because it went too far the fact is the
word pride has been tainted by the
Relentless demand to celebrate it pride
can't be mandated how can you be proud
of something you can't control it's a
deadly sin for a reason instead be proud
of what you do not who you do
or who you are
sure I may be a 10 but I Was Born This
Way
but you should see what I could do with
my uvula
see the difference there it's what I do
not who I am that matters
and really why expect players to express
loyalty to something that they might not
believe in you're not changing anybody's
Minds you're just making them resent you
for pushing them around I mean do you
really think anybody will stop being a
bigot thanks to a different Jersey
that's like expecting the view to be
slowed down by a nutritional label on a
bag of Doritos
yeah
nope the people forcing this on you
expect you to be afraid like when Brian
stelter asks to use your bathroom
never over
it'll never die ever over look we all
believe in live it let live but enough
of the compulsory Oaths Pride days Pride
months replacing pronouns activists
praying on confused kids the bullied are
now the bullies and your obedience is
their lunch money
but look there's a fundamental human
reaction when you're pressured to do
something and that is not to do it even
when it's right anything that smacks of
forced Behavior always takes us off it's
why I hated school or when Larry makes
this empty our pockets when we leave his
house
at Fox there are days when the hosts are
asked to wear a specific color to
represent an illness where red reads an
email it's for heart disease where pink
reads another for breast cancer and
please bring a banana to commemorate
Peyronie's disease
[Laughter]
I am a jerk
but also everyone else does it often
without questioning or perhaps caring so
I think it's lame and there's no color
or Jersey for that
[Applause]
that hair stylist at Fox struggle to
cover her Halo oh some Fox News Sunday
and breathe
he was on the cover of Fortune
Magazine's swimsuit edition host of
Kudlow on Fox Business Larry Kudlow
she's like sand blonde gritty and your
mom gets mad which he finds her in your
car but she's contributor attack tip
and finally when he skinny dips it
causes coastal flooding my massive
sidekick in the NWA World Heavyweight
Champion Tyrese
Shannon I have a working theory that I
think we are now going to see this kind
of Correction where we all collectively
realize that politics and fun don't mix
like in every Arena where it happens
this happens there's always some kind of
cleave or this conflict that is
completely unnecessary yeah just ask
ESPN what's happened to their ratings
yeah I mean they're seeing the real
world impact of this and the thing is we
had this Wall Street Journal stuff out
um polling a few days ago that said all
of these things are tapering off in
society like faith and patriotism and
all this kind of stuff but the idea of
Tolerance that we should be tolerant of
other people has dropped from 80 percent
to 58 in the last four years so a lot of
people are like no we don't have to
tolerate other people's ideas and that
can work in a lot of different
directions but when I think about these
things with the sports teams and the
jerseys and players having to come out
and make an individual choice or
discussion about what they're going to
do don't you want people who like
genuinely are very supportive of
whatever your thing is it's like going
to the cake baker and saying I know you
hate my guts and you don't support what
I'm doing doing but I want you to make
this cake wouldn't you rather have
somebody who's like I feel joyful about
supporting you and whatever the cause is
I don't know how corporations and sport
teams are going to continue to pick and
choose which things are going to force
everybody to agree that they love and
want to support yeah and the thing is it
is true Larry if it's forced on you then
it's not real When anybody asks me to do
something I just instinctively don't
want to do it and that's kind of like
part of being an American it's like
bucking the trend saying you know what
you can't make me do this
I kind of like to be asked myself yes
depending on what the ask is I know Greg
I know but I play hard to get I think
fans sports fans of which I'm one of
whom I want are sick of politics in
sports absolutely sick of it and I think
in general I think people are tired of
gender politics in general we've gone
way too far on that and I just want to
say that the New York Rangers are going
to win the Stanley Cup this year it's
very important
I think without any politics I'll take
the Yankees won their home opener this
morning this afternoon Aaron judge hit a
home run Garrett Cole pitched a gem so
there you have it I'm a sports fan I
don't give a damn about these politics
not one single damn yeah and I think
it's I think it's only a few people cat
right that are in that have graduated
from their from their you know ivy
league with these newfangled ideas and
they take them to their companies like
the NHL and they impress it upon
management and Management's too scared
to say anything next thing you know
every hockey player is wearing a dress
whoa
yes um
does this happen on Fox Business
um uh well so compulsory activism is not
activism so it doesn't matter any of
these players how they feel about this
or any issue regardless of where they
stand on it if anyone were to ask them
why are you wearing that the only
accurate answer would be because the
corporation I work for told me to
exactly that even if they do believe in
whatever cause it is in this case lgbt2
TQ Community it still wouldn't be the
reason they didn't go pick that patch
out and decide to put it on because oh I
support this community so much this was
given to them like hey wear this that's
not an inspiring thing that's not
activism it's really it's really kind of
and to have all these arguments over
something that's like so cheap and
forced in the first place uh you're not
actually supporting anybody you're not
supporting anybody you're basically
saying I'm getting paid by these people
yeah so I just want to get you to wear
them yeah and it's like and I don't even
think people want to fight on this hill
it's like yeah I'll put on the Jersey
but if you don't want to put on the
Jersey then you get grief that's the
problem well as athlete you're always
you're there to just try to play the
game at the best of your ability and
then you try to block out the other
stuff but there's levels to this you
know and and whether it's Pride night or
Star Wars night or because I have I have
season tickets I go to my Pelicans games
because I can't get to the Celtics game
and fake news by the way the Bruins are
going to win but um but the best record
but um the point is though the players
don't have to be the pawns you can we we
had just had Pride night at the Pelicans
game and they had the big banners and
supported and they changed the the color
of the stick She Bangs when you don't
want the guys to make the free throws
but the jerseys and they played the game
so you had a choice of support this is
the night tonight embrace it cool
halftime show represented they did the
same thing though and that's fine that's
that's great everyone can choose to be a
part of it or not when you decide and
it's one person to force things on
people to say wear this jersey to try to
shove it down their throat so to speak
and make them represent you it just I'm
glad to to see that we are living in a
time where guys can say no now right you
know and so what if they don't like you
on Twitter Twitter's not a real place
right you know what but good for them
for saying no one more people because
it's contagious it started out with one
guy now you had a whole team that said
no and and that's good because maybe it
will spread and we'll stop seeing the
Ridiculousness of what happened with
major league baseball with the with the
Hank Aaron one of the greatest baseball
players of all time celebrating his life
his career as a brave in Denver yes
morons no it's crazy I don't hurt black
businesses yeah I think if that were to
happen again it wouldn't happen like in
this I think we've all we've all seen
that it's gone too far and now I think
you're seeing the correction I hope hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else